I've never had a wallet in my life
that's what I like to keep my money raw
saw signals underneath you know that
trick
you put a hundred on top you put the
rest ones you got a fat wad this is
Action Bronson and these are my
essentials
[Music]
when traveling this is a very necessary
thing I traveled the world with one of
these in my in my pocket
I don't sneak I'm not sneaking the best
way to sneak is in plain sight I just
tell you tell him something else
I've only been questioned once and it
was reasonable for them to question me
because I had three or four different
colored substances wrapped in parchment
paper and I let them know it's vegetable
glycerin what am I doing with that like
I don't know I just made that up and
they were all right you're free to go
this is a disease the germ the iPad my
friend and road manager mark - Jesus
plays a lot of video games non-stop
vainglory so you'll just see him on the
[ __ ] iPad like that sitting in the
same room 10 hours straight not one word
he's an essential did you say hi let's
mark - Jesus this man isn't essential to
me as well I [ __ ] out of here but this
also doubles as my TV screen for all the
different sporting events that I've
missed while on the road this is my
television right here let me just be
honest with you
cocoa butter is more than essential it
live-ins up your skin it makes you glow
but I have a secret you have to buy the
stretch mark version there's nothing
that's gonna take away these stretch
marks but this right here this has added
argan oil almond oil shea butter
collagen elastin that's not in the
regular cocoa butter and it smells
better you put it on your head your face
your legs and you'll be good for days
honestly three days worth of Sheen
[Music]
give me the goddamn thing
this right here major league Rawlings
baseball American League when I was
younger I had the baseball with the
fingerprints in it you know the ones
that showed you how to throw the
different pitches I always imagined that
and I always had that in my hands I just
need to have the ball in my hand some
sort of athletic component could have
been in the major leagues at one point
possibly who knows you never know how
things go I had to travel with this this
is a necessity and I'm gonna show you my
next essential it's a little shoe it was
a little shoe that we put on our little
dog Coco that passed away it's a little
sock he used to wear these because he
would slide on the floor he was old so
he put these on for grip and inside this
I've only shown to people this it's a
piece of cactus quartz spirit they keep
it near here to me brings me good luck
good vibes all right Pete Coco coquito
Pedro Salazar Arce Lonnie at the first
rest in peace
[Music]
we have sent sent is very very important
so this is Bulgari extreme it's been
discontinued I'm gonna order another one
from an off-brand website 50% off you
know we also have some unbelievable like
floral stuff flown in from Columbia
recently came this little purple bodice
for women but I like it I like it
I wear with secret deodorant I've tried
all these natural things it doesn't stop
my man smell my mother described it as
like onion soup and it's [ __ ] pungent
it's strong you know so I feel like
secret is the only thing that actually
combats it this happens to be a natural
beverage of my creation Stillwater 7,000
it's a beer a sour dry hopped with the
Muscat grapes I [ __ ] really don't
like beer at all but I really like these
beers I really like sours they taste
more like a sparkling wine with a little
bit of to me you know it's up my alley i
pair it with hash I like to pair
different hashes with beverages natural
wines beers
this right here is essential the natural
wine essential it's a gun case
so I like to keep different things well
Oh what do I have here I just have like
a little glass sculpture a little cat
Japanese design American made it's a
beautiful collaboration between a
Japanese artist named disc and an
American artist named Joe P that [ __ ]
turns pink and another light it gets
crazy I smoked out of that yeah there's
a hole right there you put a nail there
and you
you have to have a good bag when you're
traveling look nothing happened to it
nothing happened to it it's a good bag
you know Columbia chief collaboration
and you also need shoes this happens to
be a collaboration with the dealers I'm
doing ultra boosts
I don't know which ones to do so I'm
going to ask for some help
GQ audience make sure you let me know
which ones you want to see out there on
people's feet
I like these I like these I like all of
them maybe we could do them all
Revlon hair straightening temperature
control Flatiron no I use this little
gadget to press out my my hash I get the
hash and then I put it in a coffee
filter and I do my little process and I
press it with this the hash never
touches this it's in between parchment
paper in a coffee filter so everything
leaks into the parchment paper it's a
beautiful process it's gorgeous
you need all these books to write
different rhymes and I can't write in
just one book I have to constantly go
through different ones let's see what
they got here this [ __ ] is so wavy I
need a full body doo rag I was feeling
good let's see what else I got drugs got
me emotional
smoking potion and the whip soft brown
leather you know I'm [ __ ] all over
that [ __ ] diamonds all over my dick that
wasn't written on there at all
I got some some graffiti I try to do a
like a Hedy symbol it's like outer space
and aliens it's like a triangle and
another just kind of like a Jewish star
but it's not and then they put like a
circle around it which makes it crazy
I just doodle well this is art right
here you need this record Bosphorus
bridges a Turkish jazz and funk
compilation from the 70s I mean look at
it look at this guy right here virus
Michael is one of the most legendary
Turkish pop stars that there is Michael
Jackson bearish Michael I first
discovered this album when I was making
a dr. lecktor album my first project I
rapped on it it's on one of the it's on
the album and then from there I found
this project and it's pretty much
changed my outlook on music and allowed
me to go to another level of poetry the
last thing is you need yourself a good
pair of sunglasses you need two
sunglasses in fact you need a more GQ
style of sunglasses these are Dior and
these were you want to look rough and
rugged and tactical you come through it
the Oakley M frame which I have tattooed
on my arm because no one wears these
[ __ ] things like me baby so yeah two
pairs of sunglasses one on the front one
on the back get crazy how we go